تقول بتقول حازم انه بالعوده الى فكره
الثورات انه الثورات هي تصنع المدن اما
الارياف قد تصنع الحروب الاهليه بمعنى
يعني انا فهمتك حسب ما فهمت هذا انه
الارياف فيه دائما بتصدر بتصدر للاحزاب
الاحزاب اللي هي تتزعم السلطه احيانا
بتصدر هذا الكم من الناس والفقراء اذا صح
القول يعني الاقل بيدور واحد يقول
منو
الثورات الفلاحيه انتجت
الصين كبوديه فيتنام الى اخره انتجت واحد
من اثنين يا انتجت انظمه مستبده
المدن هي اللي تنتج ثورات ولا سيما
بالمعنى جديد للثورات يعني
الثوره على الاقل يعني
بمعناها اللي اضافيته ثورات اوروبا الوسطى
ثورات اوروبا الوسطى والشرقيه اللي اسقطت
عمليا الانظمه الشيوعيه هاي الثورات اضافت
كثيره معاني لكلمه ثوره كلمه ثوره
تعرفها بالف طريقه يعني في ناس بيعرفوها
انه طبقات تسقط طبقه في يعني
الثوره
الاوروبيه الشرقيه والوسطى هي اولا سلميه
قايمه على حركه او تحرك المجتمع المديني
المدني
ما في زعيم ما في ايديولوجيا ما في عقيده
ما في حزب مركزي هذا كل هالمعاني هيدي
معاني مدينيه صعب تكون معاني
لسبب بتحس انه اذا انتقلت ركيزه الثوره من
المدينه للريف فهذا اشاره لانه ثوره
انتكست واخذت الحرب الاهليه ممكن يطلع
وهذا ما حدث في العربيه العربي صحيح صحيح